Doug shifted his stance the white ruffle
on her short denim miniskirt swayed her
locket would be the humid breeze and the
matching white South looking cotton tab
did below one shoulder revealing creamy
white skin and stark contrast with fire
rich air that screamed touch me and he
wanted to so this is the sony ebook
reader its retails for 299 and it comes
in this special red leather soft velvety
to the touch case oh that is nice yeah
it would protect it when you drop it
after your quick right after reading a
passage in the end you're shaking you
shaking passion and regret it actually
comes with a Harlequin romance novel I
believe the romance novel is called
secret fantasy and also if you do
purchase it you get certificate you can
use to get six more pumpkin romance
novels for free on the e-book reader if
I give this to my girlfriend I would
totally expect her to break up with me
immediately after she opened it if you
gave this to your girlfriend I would
bring it with you so nothing says I love
you like a book reader right what's that
day what's what that pinky things oh
this little thing right here yeah why
this is the msi wind u100 this is a
netbook
so did you buy that for me for
Valentine's Day well so aside from the
the beautiful pink gloss what's what's
going on there's actually nothing else
involved in visited that makes it like a
Valentine's Day or girly gadget it's
basically your standard netbook is
you've got an atom processor on it's got
a winking Ram it's got no optical drive
it's basically met for cloud computing
and surfing the internet you're gonna
give your wife something for Valentine's
Day i am going to give my wife something
for Valentine's so if you gave that to
her would you be a uh you know we should
embrace you or would she be hit you with
divorce papers I think she'd actually
hit me with this what if i told you i
had a 10 inch screen is that something
you'd be interested in um not personally
but i would say it's probably the best
10 inches you've ever given anyone this
nurse for a cartoon from the 80s uh
about these underwater creatures that
had like these um like I guess he seems
yeah the tubes coming out their heads
and I bow they have blue bubbles and
they blew bubbles and stuff like that
they were act I really like watching it
it was an enjoyable show and then my mom
saw me watching and she's like no you
can't watch this so this basically is a
petrified snork that fell down and
gutted it's been gutted and have a
speaker put into it I guess these are
designed for to give people on
Valentine's Day your soml thighs it like
your honey I love you is it am i right
is that the word pink show up in the
name of the product yes it's for the
color blind and people who know
satellite speakers or 15 watts apiece so
they deliver you know pretty good sound
and then also this dock comes with an
adapter in it so any size ipod even know
your olds old-school ipod will work with
it or and i think i mean is this for is
this for your lady to take in travel or
is it no no no these are definitely for
her office for her desktop shirt for
prison or imprisoned right okay yeah
it's 0 to 99 did another heavy they're
stylish your stylist um there's a
stylish if you love pink or her color
blind well there's four ports for each
the speaker is line in all right i'm
starting lineup for like a like
headphones but there's nothing for a
subwoofer she's nose up we report so the
only base you're going to get is what's
coming out of these guys right so basic
you wouldn't want to give this to the
the audiophile lady in your life no no
or pink lover I don't want to be sexist
right your your ping another if I gave
us two to my lady she would probably
take this and take about the pointy bits
and then clogged me over the head with
it repeatedly did they come in other
colors flowers chocolate diamond
earrings candy listen to me those things
are not going to help you on Valentine's
Day you want to get your girl gadgets
and a lot of them yes and all you girls
out there just act surprised when he
gives you the catcher's